[Musique]
john est ce le serait pas logo mais pas
qu'on soit au sujet des sciences de nous
a lancé très bien être en communion
salive vivra cette ambiance et la tan je
viens tout le temps regardez un match
pas sur tout cas c'est mon équipe qui
joue mon équipe du cameroun
et j'ai anticipé j'ai stocké la boisson
parce que c'était faux parce qu'ils
pouvaient avoir des ruptures
d'habitude je suis en moins c'est à lui
que je suis dans les quarante cinq
casiers de bière maintenant je suis à
près de 75 tout simplement
sa double issad oublie tout simplement
et du coup ça me fait du bien oui venez
ça me fait du bien puisque l'agent entre
de la caisse
en temps normal nous produisons à peu
près 400 litres de boisson gazeuse à peu
près 9 100 millilitres de deux bières
avec la can comme on apprend dans les
mêmes dispositions que descend pendant
les fêtes pour son mât peu près à 500
mille litres de boissons gazeuses et un
million de litres de bière
on a
contenu du trafic dense en temps normal
de douala et en plus avec la la can on a
dû revoir les horaires
d'approvisionnement pour faire en sorte
d'approvisionner de distribuer dans la
nuit et essayez donc d'éviter le trafic
dense en journée en surtout pendant les
jours de match
nous misons quand même sur une
croissance entre 15 et 20% pour
supplémentaires sur la période de calme